well
let me ask you about uh the most uh
sort of this this uh this this podcast
isn't about information it's about drama
okay let me talk to you about some drama
so you mentioned
pascal and colon equals
there's something that's called the
walrus operator okay
and uh python in python 3.8 added
the walrus operator and the reason i
think it's interesting
uh is not just because of the feature it
does it's it has the same kind of
expression feature you can mention to
see that it returns
the value of the assignment and maybe
you can comment
on that in general but on the other side
of it it's
also the thing that that uh
toppled the dictator uh so it finally
drove guido to uh step down from
edf all the toxicity of the community so
maybe um
what do you think about the walrus
operator in in python is there an
equivalent
thing in swift that really
uh stress tested the community and uh
and then on the flip side what do you
think about guido stepping down over it
yeah well if like if i look past the
details of the walrus operator one of
the things that makes it most polarizing
is that it's
syntactic sugar okay what do you mean by
syntactic sugar it means you can take
something that already exists in
language and you can express it in a
more concise way
so okay i'm gonna play doubles advocate
so uh yeah this is great
uh is that a objective or subjective
statement
like can you can you argue that
basically anything isn't syntactic sugar
or not no no you not everything is a
syntactic sugar so for example um the
type system
like can you have classes versus
uh versus uh like do you have types or
not
right so so one type versus many types
is not something that affects
syntactic sugar and so if you say i want
to have the ability to define types
i have to have all this like language
mechanics to define classes
and oh now i have to have inheritance
and i have like i have all this stuff
that's just making language more
complicated
that's not that's not about sugaring it
um
swift has sugar so like swift has this
thing called if let and
it has various operators are used to
concisify
uh specific use cases so the problem
with syntactic sugar
when you're talking about hey i have a
thing that takes a lot to write and i
have a new way to write it
you have this like horrible trade-off
which becomes
almost completely subjective which is
how often does this happen and does it
matter
and one of the things that is true about
human psychology particularly when you
talk about introducing a new thing
is that people over overestimate
the burden of learning something and so
it looks foreign when you haven't gotten
used to it
but if it was there from the beginning
of course it's just part of python
like unquestionably like this is just
the thing i know
and it's not a new thing that you're
worried about learning it's just part of
part of the deal
now with guido uh i i don't know
guido well um yeah have you passed
across much
yeah i've met him a couple of times but
i don't know guido well
but the the sense that i got out of that
whole dynamic was that he had put the
not just the decision maker weight on
his shoulders
but it was so tied to his personal
identity
that um he took it personally and he
felt the need and he kind of put himself
in the situation of being
the person instead of building a base of
support around him
i mean he this is probably not quite
literally true
but by too much so that there's too much
too much concentrated on him
right and so and that can wear you down
well yeah particularly because people
then say
guido you're a horrible person i hate
this thing blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah and sure it's like you know maybe
one percent of the community that's
doing that
but python's got a big community and one
percent of it
of millions of people is a lot of hate
mail and that just
from human factor will just wear on you
what to to clarify it looked from
just what i saw in the messaging for the
let's not look at the million python
users but at the
python core developers it feels like the
majority
the big majority on a vote were opposed
to it
okay i'm not that close to it so i don't
know so so this okay so the situation is
like literally
uh yeah i mean the majority of the core
developers against
it and they weren't
they weren't even like against it
it was uh there was a few well they were
against it but the against it wasn't
like
this is a bad idea they were more like
we don't see why this is a good idea and
what that results in
is there's a stalling feeling like you
you just slow things down now from my
perspective
now you could argue this and i think
it's a very
it's very interesting if we look at
politics today and the way congress
works it's slowed down
everything it's a dampener yeah it's a
dampener but like that's a dangerous
thing too because if it dampens things
like
you know dampening results what are you
talking about like it's a low-pass
filter but if you need billions of
dollars injected into the economy
for trillions of dollars then suddenly
stuff happens
right and so for sure so
i'm talking situation just to be clear
but you're talking about like uh a
global pandemic
i was hoping we could fix like the
health care system
and the educations and like you know uh
i'm not i'm not a
politics person i don't i don't i don't
know um when it comes to languages
the community is kind of right in terms
of it's a very high burden to add
something to a language
so as soon as you add something you have
a community of people building on it and
you can't remove it
okay and if there's a community of
people that feel really uncomfortable
with it
then taking it slow i think is is is an
important thing to do
and there's no rush particularly with
something that's 25 years old and is
very established and
you know it's not like coming coming
into its own um
features well so i think that the issue
with
with guido is that maybe this is a case
where he realized it
had outgrown him and it went from being
or the language the language so python i
mean guido is amazing
but but python isn't about guido anymore
it's about the users
and to a certain extent the users own it
and you know
guido spent years of his life a
significant fraction of his career
on python and from his perspective i
imagine he's like well
this is my thing i should be able to do
the thing i think is right
but you can also understand the users
where they feel like you know
this is my thing i use this like and um
and i don't know it's it's a hard it's a
hard thing but what
if we could talk about leadership in
this because it's so interesting to me
i'm gonna i'm gonna make
i'm gonna work hopefully somebody makes
it if not i'll make it a water stop for
your shirt because
i think it represents to me maybe it's
my russian roots or something
uh you know it's the burden of
leadership
like i feel like to push back
i feel like progress can only like most
difficult decisions just like you said
there will be a lot of
divisiveness over yeah especially in the
passionate community
it just feels like leaders need to take
those
risky decisions that that if you
like listen that with some
non-zero probability maybe even a high
probability would be the wrong decision
but they have to use their gut and make
that decision
well this this is like one of the things
where you see uh
amazing founders the founders understand
exactly what's happened and why how the
company got there and are willing to say
to we have been doing a thing x the last
20 years
but today we're going to do thing y and
they make a major pivot for the whole
company
the company lines up behind them they
move and it's the right thing
but then when the founder dies the
successor
doesn't always feel that that agency
to be able to make those kinds of
decisions yeah even though the ceo they
could theoretically do whatever
there's two reasons for that in my
opinion or
in many cases it's always different but
um one of which is
they weren't there for all the decisions
that were made and so they don't know
the principles
in which those decisions were made and
once the principles change
you're you should be obligated to change
what you're doing and change direction
right and so if you don't know how you
got to where you are it just seems like
gospel
and you know you're not going to
question it you may not understand that
it really
is the right thing to do so you just may
not see it that's so brilliant i never
thought of it
that way like it's it's so much higher
burden
when as a leader you step into a thing
that's already worked for a long time
yeah
yeah well and if you change it and it
doesn't work out now you're the person
who screwed it up
people always second guess that yeah and
the second thing is even if you decide
to make a change
even if you're theoretically in charge
you're just you're just a person
that thinks they're in charge meanwhile
you have to motivate the troops you have
to explain it to them in terms they'll
understand you have to get them to buy
into and believe in it because if they
don't
then they're not going to be able to
make the turn even if you tell them
you know their bonuses are going to be
curtailed they're just not going to like
buy into it
you know and so there's only so much
power you have as a leader and
you have to understand what that what
those limitations are
you